Reggie Miller the Hall of Famer Reggie's
second annual fundraiser for the
dropping dimes foundation is going on
right now partnering with Castelli to
sell boom baby jerseys and kits the sale
runs through June all profits go to DTF
with reggie matching the funds raised
check his Instagram bio or the net seed
that's in store Castelli us.com products
for more information
reg to tell the audience a little bit
more about this well again it's the
fundraiser and the legacy that I'm
continuing to have it live on through
Mel Daniels who was one of my mentors
one of the great ABA players in Indiana
Pacers of all time he always wanted to
take care of those great ABA players
remember the ABA the NBA bought ABA
basically out and merged with them and
all the great players dr. J Moses Malone
George Gervin and all the great players
had a chance to jump from the ABA to the
NBA well there was a lot of players that
didn't get that call and there was no
pension no health care and that's what a
lot of these cost go towards and I like
to merge both of my loves obviously
taking care of the great players that
paved the way for a lot of us I'm a huge
ABA they're the ones that have the red
white and blue ball and it really shot
the three and these players paved the
way for a lot of the NBA players for
these crazy amount of salaries that they
get now so to merge my love of the ABA
as well as cycling and to give back
because a lot of these cost go towards
the medical they don't have any pension
they have nowhere for health care and I
just love taking care of the people that
paved the way for personally for myself
it's dropping dimes foundation what's
the website they can go to for more
information reg they can go on my
Instagram
Reggie Miller TNT or my Twitter Reggie
Miller TNT or go to at testily cycling
and all three have the website all four
jerseys are available in four different
colors men and women sizes so for those
of you who love the great outdoors and
love being on two wheels and cycling
either Mountain
or Road or a cross between cyclo these
jerseys are for you and the famous boom
baby signatures from Slick Leonard the
coach of the ABA Indiana Pacers who when
we would make big threes it was boom
baby so that's where boom baby
originated from good stuff good stuff
thank you brother
you know we're breaking down a whole lot
with LeBron and jr. as they went into
overtime in Game one that you know
they're the critics are out with LeBron
that he should have been more nurturing
or a better teammate to to jr. and I
guess we're always going to get in to
the you know this same picture and it's
what would Michael Jordan have done I
know had done that now I don't getting
there because I know that Michael would
have been angrier than LeBron was at
junior because Mike would give his
teammates the look you know Mike could
be mean-spirited to his teammates so
LeBron didn't nurture junior should we
be roughing up LeBron after junior Smith
has this boneheaded play and they're
going into overtime and LeBron is still
seething absolutely not it's hard for me
to nurture someone who's making millions
of dollars and should know time and
score I understand being a good teammate
that's one thing yeah
and giving someone the silent treatment
I think everyone I think LeBron was in
shock truthfully if you look at you know
what I was seeing online there was dead
silence for a minute and a half on that
Cavs bench and then it turns out he
finds out that tyloo had a timeout the
Cavs had a timeout there's a lot of
blame to go along here and it's a team
game
the Cavs along with LeBron James lost a
game JR Smith did not lose their game
because there's a lot of blame to go
along you go around
number one make a free throw George Hill
you waited your whole life to be in this
moment to get to the NBA Finals that's
not Tristan Thompson at the free-throw
line
you look like a deer in headlights that
free-throw had no shot of going so make
a free throw and we net
are talking about JR Smith number two
once you do mr. free-throw tyloo you
know you have a timeout you should have
been Usain Bolt and running all the way
onto the court the officials aren't
going to give you a technical when
you're out there running trying to call
a timeout you won't you got caught up in
the moment
tyloo needs to take a little bit of
responsibility as well you as a coach
knew you had a timeout and number one
thing as all players when you're
calculated to bench and last-second
moments the one thing LeBron Jerry Smith
Tristan Thompson Kevin Love you're
always saying how many timeouts do we
have loved one we have one in 220 so
everyone should have been mentioning
that in anticipation of a missed free
throw from George Hill as soon as the
rebound was secured everyone should have
been calling timeout tyloo should have
been sprinting on the floor calling a
timeout
so there's blame to go all the way
around it's like we always got to come
back and be like LeBron well this is
what Michael will be done stop blaming
LeBron do scored 51 points and damn near
had a triple-double and you lose on the
road to me there is no coming back there
is no coming back in this series when
you let a game like that slip away I
thought they were going to come out with
a little bit more resilient see in Game
two a little bit more fight but they
didn't their head other than LeBron
James are gone they're gone it's hard to
recover when you you've had you had the
champs on the ropes and you let it slip
away how would you have reacted I
probably I probably would have acted
like LeBron I probably would have hit
jr. like when they're sitting on the
bench next to one another because you
got to remember you still have to
prepare for overtime yeah by this moment
they're getting ready for overtime I
probably hit them and say alright get
your head back into it let's go I
probably would have done that and left
it at that
but behind closed doors once we got into
the locker room I probably would have
went into a tirade then like you
half-wit what the hell are you thinking
how could you not
I probably been a little bit more crazy
in the locker room did you ever
teamate no not in public you never do
that where everyone is watching because
once you step on the court there are a
million cameras on you and you just
can't show up your teammate in public
now behind closed doors that's a
different that's different you can get
in people's faces but you never want to
embarrass your teammate because again i
revert back it's a team game you need
junior you need Kevin Love
you need Thompson you need kyle korver
so to berate and to belittle in public
where people are watching the silent
treatment I think LeBron and the rest of
the Cavs were a little bit in shock like
I can't believe we blew this game but
you never want to belittle a teammate in
public in front of everyone behind
closed doors you can be a little bit
more demonstrative but I think LeBron
was in shock and again it always reverts
back to he gets the blame I know it's
not cool man it's not cool
my junior makes the mistake tyronn lue
doesn't call timeout but somehow it's on
the bran because he wasn't nice to
Junior Smith in the huddle nice to a guy
that's making 16 million dollars a year
that should no time look your plane or
in Oracle near Silicon Valley they've
got the biggest scoreboard
Tindle the most digital tech arena maybe
ever how can you not know what the score
is how can you not know that it's tied
it's the Oracle there was a moment to
which with Steph Curry and the Warriors
were upset with Kendrick Perkins with
his feet Nazz legs are out he's not even
in unify don't know why this guy he's
somehow worked his way into the the NBA
playoffs here and he doesn't play what
is what is the protocol there that you
know when you're shooting and you step
back and you're close to the bench guys
are supposed to move their feet right
you would assume so again you never want
to injure any any player because
obviously we all make a living we all
had me made a living through a
basketball but he never won a keys don't
you think that there's some intent there
I hope not I want to always give people
the benefit done I don't know what's in
kinder Perkins head we know that he got
into it with Drake in that Toronto
series you know and he was in in plain
clothes look he's their enforcer right
and he's trying to enforce in his
civvies and it's very difficult when
you're not dressed out I hope again I
don't know what's in kinder Perkins head
I hope he wasn't purposely trying to
pull a Pachulia remember they changed
the rule on that you know last year's
when Kawhi Leonard in that series got
hurt
coming down on Pachulia 's foot so I
hope that's not the case because you
want both teams at full strength and you
would hate for a staff or you know we've
seen that clay is hobbling around on a
bum ankle but you know still doing
business I hope that's not the case I
really don't in an amazing though we
still forget not like link when Steph
Curry has one of those games or one of
those quarters one of those hounds we go
that's right he's still really really
good how did how do we sort of is Durant
that good that he pushed Steph to the
backburner here I I've always felt that
Durant was the Alpha on this team in
terms of scoring but the engine and we
said this in that Houston series the
engine for the Warriors is 100% Steph
Curry he's the one that makes them go
he's it's a different buzz in that
building
when Kevin Durant goes on a scoring run
it's one thing but when you hear the
buzz when Steph gets it clicking it's a
different noise level and he's the one
that gets the motion the ball movement
the threes and then the shimmies and
it's a different energy that you see
from the Warriors now when the game is
closed and tied and you need a bucket
I'm going to Katie but when you're in
the middle of those runs ten oh twelve
oh you know 15 overruns
head of the snake to me always is Steph
Curry and it's overdue hopefully if they
do end up winning this
he'll probably be Finals MVP I thought
he should have been the Finals MVP the
year that Andre Iguodala want it but
it's long overdue because uh two-time
MVP he deserves it
what do you think of the officials and
the after-the-fact admitting that they
made mistake do you
does that help you in any way if you're
Lamar land when they go you know what
further review we made a mistake we
missed it no stop throwing them under
the bus and here's my problem a human
error is a part of the game so either
bring another official and have him
courtside and doing nothing but watching
the monitor and when he sees an error
stands up or put the flag up and the
official comes over and changes it
immediately or let human air be a part
of the game and live with it I'm tired
of them going to the monitor and taking
10 minutes on a simple call either let
human air be a part of the game which it
had been or call everything call the
goaltending that LeBron had against
Victor Oladipo don't say oh we didn't
call it on the court so we can't go back
and review it but yet when he gets a
charge you can go back and say he was
outside the restricted area but he
wasn't in a legal guardian position so
we're gonna change the call no either
change everything go to the monitor and
you can change whatever call you want
goaltending or blocks or charges or let
human error be a part of the game it
can't be halfway how about you give a
coach's challenge I give you I give you
one per half is that is that too much
are we opening the door to you know
slowing down the game even more yes we
are it's too slow now we they go to the
monitor way too often way too much and
it bogs down the game it really does
so either have the ability to correct
every single call which is going to slow
down the game or let human air be a part
of it you're okay with human error
I look I live through it I know but but
but but but if you would have known that
they could have reviewed something would
you have been for that when you played
no human error
I like human error okay now the only
thing that that you know when the ball
gets tipped out of bounds and like that
and you don't know who it goes off of
them to me that I thought that's what
review was always for but not to see the
gold tin by LeBron James
on Victor Oladipo and not go back and
change that but then you're gonna change
the block charge on him in the NBA
Finals when one official called it a
charge but you go to review thing he
wasn't it people at home were like what
are you guys are talking about the
average fan is like wait a minute didn't
you just call it charge now you're
calling it a block it just changes it
changes the complexity of the game are
you looking at any of these guys who are
coming out in the draft I think we have
Trey young who's gonna join us is that
coming up in a week or so you know so
trying to handicap who can make who's a
difference maker have you seen enough of
these guys that if I think DeAndre Aten
could be a difference maker the 7-footer
from Arizona in today's game I know he's
not a great defensive player but in
terms of offense especially if he
develops you know facing the basket and
being able you know to shoot a you know
15 to 18 footer he has the size he could
run he has the length to be in their
lettuce ISM to be a good defensive
player he's just not there yet
the kid from Croatia
I've just seen tapes of him don't cheer
nineteen-year-old yeah they say he's
good I haven't seen a lot of film on him
you know it's gonna be interesting on
entree because people call him baby
Steph Steph if you if you're up close
with Steph he is a big stick what to 63
yeah with long arms when we called the
Oklahoma gave us when they were playing
Alabama during the n-c-double-a yeah
Tekin absolutely flat I'll shoot the
basketball but he's not very big so it's
gonna be interesting to see how his game
can translate at the next level but he
does have a skill set and the skill set
is being able to shoot the basketball
you know I just wonder the the
physicality here that we always talk
about with him on the floor and you know
is Jim Jimmer Fredette is built more for
the NBA than tray youngest as far as
size goes but Theodore we said that
about Steph oh he's too slight he's not
gonna make it you know it's really a
point guard can he play point and you
know he's a hybrid and you know to
regular-season the MVPs later you know
he's gonna arguably go down as the
greatest shooter ever well they doubted
you
and you were what six seven and 100 and
170 it'd be very kind here did you try
to have it on wait peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches were I yeah I tried it
just was my metabolism I like it I could
eat and I could walk you know and be
gone it's still amazing though because
people don't realize this story that you
were so slight and they they worried
about how you ran if right when you got
drafted weren't they worried about you
know that I had to wear braces up until
I was five years old because my feet
were you know outwards so they had to
wear braces to bring my feet in and they
were worried about my cadence and my
gait and the way I ran but Jack Ramsey
the Hall of Famer god bless them they
believed in me
along with Donnie Walsh and they knew I
had a skill set of being able to shoot
the basketball and spread the floor and
I may have been skinny but the good
thing that they taught me at UCLA I did
so many pull-ups and push-ups so I was
wiry strong I just wasn't like he
couldn't push me and I go down at least
I held my ground so I knew I was you
know I wasn't huge on lifting weights
but I did tons of pull-ups and push-ups
and sit-ups all right let's last here
let's guess the max that Reggie
do on the bench okay wait hold on hold
on we got against fritzy Reggie Miller's
max benchpress 225 225
oh no seat no counter now we're talking
about as a rookie right oh the most
you've ever done
oh okay okay seaton mmm see he feels a
little better about it ever there was a
point in time okay I'd see I'll got 235
235 Paulie 185 185 McLovin snap 195 he's
got long arms and it's tough when you
got long arms I'm gonna I'd like to go
to Hyundai right on the nose there
Reggie Miller max benchpress is 205 I
know there's a lot of NFL players that
are like yes 205 yeah you're right about
the long arms and bringing it all the
way down so I used to put a box on my
chest so I didn't have to come all the
way down my chest and Cheryl did 210
right no Cheryl did 235 hey may we all
be built like you are in our 50s reg
you're in great shape with him again
thanks a bike and that's how I'm staying
so svelte and it's a Dimes foundation
that Reggie's second annual fundraiser
for the dropping dimes foundation reg
enjoy the festivities coming up tomorrow
night we'll talk to you next week
Theodore and my Dennis the best
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]